[Musique]
laure et eut tenté mais marcel thaci
douce provence si tu l'avais vécu comme
moi aujourd'hui
aurait-il fait rêver tes souvenirs
d'enfance le château de ta mère au
milieu des taudis je suis né comme toi
au pied du garlaban sans couronne de
chèvre les derniers chevrier à l'herbe
des collines avait depuis longtemps
préféré les granules des grands silos
d'acier ta petite bourgade nichée sur
les coteaux c'est devenu ma ville où
fleurit le béton le champ de ta fontaine
ou pépier les moineaux s'essouffle peu à
peu sous le cri des klaxons des sentiers
caillouteux sillonnant la campagne où tu
croises est parfois calèche les chevaux
sont tentacules noir qui perce les
montagnes et vomissent voiture en
confuse et chevaux lourds et 80 mg et
marcel thaci d'où ce provence si tu
l'avais vécu comme moi aujourd'hui
aurait-il fait rêver tes souvenirs
d'enfance le château de ta mère au
milieu des taudis des balades aux côtés
de neil idée béland les sources et les
oiseaux de vaugeois infantile ne font
plus le bonheur de nos jeunes garçons
qui préfèrent les jeux sur tablettes
tactiles toi toi tu as appris à lire os
comme un autre à marcher alors que sur
les livres vous devez tourner la page et
le verbe français que quand tu
chérissais se perd en abrégé dans leur
nouveau langage les grands éclats de
rire les tapes dans le dos sont ndr
rougeole et pousse bleus lever les je
t'aime alors d'ugolin le coeur gros sons
je te kiffe grave est trop bonne bébé
fini les jeux de cartes ou ce fan des
lakers les pot de l'amitié les franches
rigolades
le bar de la marine a perdu sa chaleur
de marius et césar fini les angles la
deûle aurait dû tenter mais marcel est
ainsi 12 provence si tu l'avais vécu
comme moins aujourd'hui
aurait-il fait rêver tes souvenirs
d'enfance le château de ta mère au
milieu des taudis
moi moi je suis né l'année où toi tu es
parti rejoindre ton livier ta mère à la
treille et pourtant dans tes mots j'ai
appris tout petit avoir le coeur des
gens au milieu des broussailles
qu'importe alors colline cigale et
garrigue ou asphalte et béton et sirènes
de flics qu'ils appellent marius
florette escartefigue ou rachel ou cindy
willan où toufik au coeur des gens d'ici
si tu grattes la croûte tu trouves le
soleil et les odeurs de thym la chaleur
la passion la même que sans doute tueur
trouvait jadis fond du coeur détient oui
tu aimerais notre douce provence tu
aimerais au moins autant que moi je
laime moi ils me font rêver mes
souvenirs d'enfance le château de ma
mère de dans son hlm
merci
[Applaudissements]